having never been able to reconcile the
notion of King George the Third's
Britain as the original enemy the Great
Satan to everything American with the
long-running sense of special
relationship between America and Britain
that my school teachers also instilled
in me I look to him for a way to heal
the kind of inner rift in my sense of
American history Kevin Phillips is a man
of many accomplishments after some early
work is a congressional staff person and
is a special assistant in the US
attorney general's office he has spent
the past 30 years as a political analyst
commentator and writer he has written a
monthly column on history and politics
for the Los Angeles Times since 1983 and
since 1984 has been a regular
commentator on National Public Radio he
has also written nine books including
the emerging Republican majority in 1969
mediocracy American parties and politics
in the communications age in 1975 post
conservative America in 1982 arrogant
capital Washington Wall Street and the
frustration of American politics in 1994
and his latest about which he will speak
and answer questions today
the Cousins Wars religion politics and
the triumph of Anglo America which was
published in 1999 most remarkably mr.
Phillips has earned the admiration of
general readers and of academic
historians and if commentators across
the political spectrum The Wall Street
Journal noted his prophetic powers of
analysis as early as 1982 noting that he
had quote invented the Sun Belt named
the new right and accurately prophesied
the emerging Republican majority in 1969
by 1990 a writer in the New York Times
Book Review described him as quote
perhaps the nation's foremost analyst of
electoral politics such accolades have
been repeated by many others but perhaps
the most remarkable came in 1993 from
then President Clinton's chief political
strategist James Carville
who said quote in the political business
very few people deserved the appellation
genius Kevin Phillips is decidedly one
of them unlikely praise perhaps but true
in the cousins Wars mr. Philips extended
his analytical reach back over almost
400 years of American and English
history to produce an original and
elegant book in a crowd of history
lovers such as this I should probably
mention also that the distinguished
historian Joseph Ellis winner of the
Pulitzer Prize last month for his
wonderful book founding brothers
described the cousins wars as quote an
admirably feisty take-no-prisoners book
in the spirit of Oliver Cromwell and
William Tecumseh Sherman two of its
leading characters and one that serious
students of English and American history
ought not miss or Dismas in his
characteristically lucid and readable
style mr. Phillips lays out the thesis
of his book early on in it
he write it is I'm sorry in his own
words quote that from the 17th century
the english-speaking peoples on both
continents Europe and North America
defined themselves by wars that upheld
at least for a while a guiding political
culture of a low church Calvinistic
Protestantism commercially adept
militantly expansionist and highly
convinced in old world new world or both
that it represented a chosen people and
a manifest destiny in the full three
century context Cavaliers aristocrats
and bishops pretty much lost and
Puritans Yankees self-made entrepreneurs
anglo-saxon nationalists and
expansionists had the edge especially in
America in support of this thesis he
marshals a vast range of historical
evidence scholarly commentary and
analytical insight his book is studded
with telling examples and interesting
nuggets from the fact that 50% of the
graduates of Harvard between 1640 and
1650 returned to England to join the
Puritan side to the observation about
Britain today that it is very well to
talk about Britain is part of Europe but
on birthdays and Christmas quote when
Britain's dial far away there are
precious few
calls to Brussels or Turin and the flood
to Nova Scotia New York and New South
Wales his book is sweeping provocative
and eloquent and when you hear him I
think you'll understand why the Gilder
Lehrman Institute of American history is
very pleased to present Kevin Phillips
that's a pleasure to be here tonight I
should say that some of these these
nuggets can cover the most fascinating
ways and in the course of going around
and speaking about the book when it came
out a couple of years ago I was told by
one fellow up in Boston that he'd gone
to a school called Roxbury Latin that
had as part of its school song
fighting the Cavaliers and they weren't
talking about some vague Cavaliers of
the 19th century they were talking about
the Cavaliers of the English Civil War
and then when I was down at the UVA I
was reminded which I'd forgotten but
University of Virginia teams are called
the Cavaliers and they too have a song
which basically I don't think it singles
out fighting the Puritans but when
they're talking about Cavaliers they're
talking about that side in the English
Civil War so there's a sense that
Americans have but that war at just
nothing to do with us the same way that
a lot of people in the UK really think
that the American Civil War had very
little to do with them and the thrust of
this book really is that these were the
three great english-speaking civil wars
the English Civil War the American
Revolution and the American Civil War
and each of them very much embroiled
both sides of the Atlantic obviously
with different degrees especially when
the future United States was very small
potatoes in the 1640s but in terms of
the importance of the embroilment of
both sides and of emerging patterns of
how some of those predilections and
alignments persisted down through the
centuries you that's one of the things
that's the most striking in all of us
when you really get into it how elements
and the American Civil War still
reflected some of these alignments and
senses of conspiracy and
belief that tyranny was the problem and
suspicions of Catholicism and
Reformation type evaluations of the
importance of the moral crusade that was
at hand you had those in the Civil War
really the same way you had them in the
English Civil War but what I'll try to
do today will be to come at this from a
somewhat different standpoint I have oh
three or four different ways in which I
developed this book in different
circumstances I was over at a conference
and just outside of London late last
year on what conservatives from both the
United States and the United Kingdom
were calling the angle of sphere and the
angle of sphere was essentially the
english-speaking countries and the
notion being afoot that everybody's
learning to speak English especially
among the elites that obviously English
is the language for now at least of
computers the digital language is
English for all practical purposes and
they were presupposing that this
entailed a great future for the the
anglo-american view of markets and of
corporate finance and of many many
things in terms of of economics I'm not
certain that my book lends itself to
that quite as much as as it might some
of the points that I made there were
that the genius of the english-speaking
political system was the unique among
the political and the linguistic
cultures of Europe the english-speaking
culture was set up in two different
types of nations one apparent obviously
was aristocratic a deferential culture
high church but in contrast to the
others it created a another major power
that under the same linguistic banner
basically stood for a much more
democratic inegalitarian culture a much
more low search
and toleration minded religion and
generally a sort of different sense of
how you act as an empire I think we here
are an empire that tries to pretend it's
not an empire and when you try to
pretend when you're an empire and you
try to pretend you're not you have to go
about it sort of carefully in the
British of course we're proud to say the
Sun never set on it anybody who looked
at a map of American army air force and
navy bases in 1950 or even 1960 it's
mind-blowing
the Sun never began to set on those
either and we don't have all that many
left but at the peak it was an empire to
match anything you ever saw on pink and
red on the globe back in in 1935 or 1945
the other angle of this book that's been
fascinating for me is the notion of
these three wars as a ladder and as a
series of wars that flow out of each
other and have common bonds and a very
very important role that goes back and
forth between the two english-speaking
countries but beyond that they also have
shaped some of the other wars and the
other wars interact with that my 10 days
or so I have to go and give a speech to
something called the the 6th annual war
college of the Seven Years War which was
1756 to 1763 but in point of fact it's
really very significant for the American
Revolution because that was when
Americans began to get the sense first
of all once the French lost Canada there
wasn't anybody to send the Indian
raiding party south and now manifest
destiny not that they called it that yet
could role and secondly that began to
get a sense they could have won some of
those battles without the partition
maybe if they had to fight the British
they could manage that too
especially when they saw these regiments
just wandering blindly around the woods
of Pennsylvania or the adder
nice and not doing too well so the
importance of the Seven Years War is
there however to me the the most
important element of this is not the the
elements that I saw in the beginning
when I segwayed into this book but the
extent to which it underscores the
enormous importance of religion in
American politics and American cultural
and political and electoral alignments
and for that matter in the wars and what
I'll try to do here in an odd sort of
way because there are so many people
here who are history teachers or
historians is to try to get into this
aspect of it from the standpoint of in a
sense the historiography involved here
how did some of these things take shape
in terms of the proof pattern I think
the proof pattern is actually pretty
overwhelming but it certainly wasn't
something that I assumed in the
beginning I came to the conclusion at
the end that the importance of religion
here was enormous
was much more than most of the other
factors and just generally wasn't nearly
recognized enough by the end of the book
and I could only deal with it really in
in an appendix I became convinced
analyzing carefully the the paranoia's
and the conspiracy theories anglo-saxon
politics is full of conspiracy theory
starting with the Gunpowder Plot and
Titus Oates and working all the way up
to McCarthy and even Hillary Clinton
with a right white right wing plot to
disclose the immorality of her husband
he managed that himself he didn't need
them so you you have this paranoid
streak in english-speaking politics
which we did not invent and we certainly
developed it beyond what the British did
in some areas but they really developed
a lot of it too and if you look at the
English Civil War and then you look at
the American Revolution and you look at
the Americans
and I'll come back and wind-up sort of
on this note but I want to set it up in
the beginning each of these war is
involved a common set of conspiracy
theories and it sounds odd and they had
different players and they had different
adjectives and different nouns but
essentially what they did is they saw
tyranny at work and they were going to
lose their rights and politics was
developing a an arrogant character
whether it was from stewart's or from
the Hanoverians or from the slave opera
C or in the case of a South they thought
it was the Yankees trying to undo the
constitutional bargain of 1787 there
were was in each of these Wars this
great sense of conspiracy of tyranny of
elites that were doing something to them
and of course the other side had usually
its own set of elites that often the
reverse and then the second aspect and
this was just as striking because it
suggested that there was a common
relationship between the two
conspiracies that they went back to the
Reformation in some respects and also to
the European Wars of the 17th and 18th
century in which there was still an
element of England standing for a
relative democracy and the Continental
power is standing for more of an
authoritarian rule elements of a Counter
Reformation against the Reformation and
it it sounds even to me saying this here
knowing that I can stand and then talk
quite a bit about it with quite a bit of
proof it seems a little odd to say we're
going to look at these three wars and
see a continuity of this sort but in
fact it really unfolds quite neatly and
if you remember the know-nothing absurd
in the 1850s before the Civil War there
again was the anti Catholic conspiracy
aspect that came in so strongly
in the English Civil War the English
revolution and before the American
Revolution and even during it as I'll
get into so that these two aspects
coming out of the the Wars of the 17th
and 18th century in Europe lingered over
here they lingered very powerfully and
if you go back and you remember even in
the 1960 election you can find religious
voting patterns in the Middle West that
are quite conspicuous and John Kennedy's
famous and very successful put-down
after the election and saying that he
had dissent the Pope a message unpack
but what that bespoke was an
understanding that in the whole history
of the United States going back at that
point even then 300 years plus that
there was this tradition part and parcel
the english-speaking heritage of
tradition tradition of suspicion with
Catholicism well now let me get to the
brass tacks of the historiography here I
mentioned in the preface of the book but
for those who haven't read it I'll
repeat it again my motivation in
starting this book back in in 1995 was
that I got sick and tired of American
politics that evolved the face-off
between the ozark kazanova and the great
Newt Gingrich two peas out of the same
pod in my book and the whole notion of
spending serious time immersing myself
and what [ __ ] knew was saying about
[ __ ] B so I figured I'd try to find
something that was was more interesting
than that and I figured well you can't
go wrong looking at things that involve
George Washington and Abraham Lincoln I
mean you can't think of a bigger
contrast frankly and so blown behold in
a way that's what I did I got started on
the American Revolution I was just going
to do something on the American
Revolution and then as I got into all
the loyalties and the
visions within the American Revolution
both in the future United States and in
Britain it sort of pulled out the
politician or political analyst in me
and I became so caught up in the the
alignments in politics and ethnic and
religious cleavages of upstate New York
in the beginning and then the whole
revolution including the divisions
within Britain that I began it turned
into a political book I guess big
surprise at that point I began thinking
because I've written the book in the
late 1960s called the emerging
Republican majority that you had three
Republican majorities that was the first
was the the first small our republican
temporary plurality I guess we have to
say an english-speaking history in the
1640s with the English Civil War then
you jump to the American Revolution and
this time it worked you had a Republican
majority that lasted small are 1860 you
get the Republican Party majority out of
the Civil War and I knew enough about
the history involved to think as I began
to get into the American Revolution in
detail you know some of these alignments
look like I've seen this before and I
know a fair amount about America and
political geography from all those years
of election watching and strategizing
and it helped to for me to know what all
these places were historically and the
further I got into it the more I became
convinced that there was a real chain a
chain between these wars a chain between
some of the psychologies that brought
them about and a chain involving the
alignments within them who took what
side now let me give you an example here
this will sound exotic but it's also I
think pretty easy to prove this was the
first way in which I got into the
practicalities of this as I started the
trying to analyze who took what side in
the American Revolution that was really
the starting point here and I was most
preoccupied with the critical battles
leading up to what I thought was was the
critical battle Saratoga and the
campaigns in upstate New York
well by the time I finished going
through all the the loyalty patterns it
became very clear that on the Tory side
on the British side you had Scots you
had Anglicans you had high church Dutch
from the lower Hudson Valley
you had Palatine Germans who worked for
Sir William Johnson you even had by the
time you got up to Quebec the Catholic
heart hierarchy of the Roman Catholic
Church in in Quebec was on the Tory side
the Mohawk Indians you might be
surprised to know had a definite
religious cleavage they they were
Anglicans Joseph Brant who was one of
their major Chiefs had been a great
friend of Sir William Johnson had been
received by King George the 3rd and they
particularly liked the Anglican Church
because it was a little loosey-goosey
morally and Sir William Johnson had
quite a few illegitimate children in the
Mohawk Valley and the Anglicans had
nothing to say about this whereas the
Presbyterians 10 20 miles away in the
Oneida Indian villages it Presbyterians
and congregations had come over from New
England and they were training the
Indians to be New Englanders and they
didn't like the idea that Sir William
Johnson had 11 or 14 or however many
illegitimate children running around and
so the the Mohawks took it all pretty
seriously and Joseph Brant has been
quoted in several histories is referring
to the Oneida Indians who fought with
the Americans as those damned
Presbyterian Indians so you start taking
all this seriously when you get into
this on the American side not just
anybody the predominant characteristic
of those on the
American side and that part of the
country was New Englanders
Congregationalist Presbyterians Dutch
Reformed as opposed to the high church
Dutch who took the British side the
Dutch Reformed Church of that period and
this is where I started becoming
convinced that this is more important
than I thought it was the Dutch Reformed
Church of that period was about to
divide between two groups that couldn't
stand each other one wanted to have
ministers who were ordained in the new
world and to be run on more Presbyterian
lines the other wanted they thought
about tying up with the Anglicans and
the ministers had to be ordained over an
Amsterdam and they almost became
dissolved and then part became Anglican
and part became Presbyterian but they
didn't do it but they fought against
each other here we are New York City
there are probably some people here who
live in Bergen County well that's where
this was bitter it was a civil war in
Bergen County between various types of
Dutch Reformed you know in suburbs were
now the only thing they can think about
as an Nasdaq and a BMW dealership back
then they were really hung up on these
other things and then you you get down
and you see that the Dutch Reformed the
low church they were on the patriotic
side with the Presbyterians and it gets
so that you start taking this stuff for
granted now I had a chance to go give a
speech over at Oxford in 1995 as I was
getting into this and I became convinced
as I started to see the pattern and the
American Revolution but you know I
wonder what it was like over in Britain
because I knew enough about it to know
that there had been a degree of support
for the colonists in Britain and it
turned out I had a bibliography done
over there and got some books and came
back and researched it pretty carefully
you can actually draw up quite easily
it's not a lot of trouble and it's not
very debatable a essentially an analysis
of who took what side within the United
Kingdom
the American Revolution and the basic
British history is well didn't really
happen or if it happened it was just a
bunch of malcontents and so forth and
that King George the Third's said that
everything was was relatively United
over there it really wasn't and though
cleavages came exactly as you might
think high church Anglicans the Church
of England the royal court strongest
supporters of the war along with a lot
of the placement the strongest support
for the Americans came from the
dissenters the Quakers the congregation
was the Presbyterians from the Welsh who
had cousins in Pennsylvania or the Welsh
Baptist from Northern Ireland Ulster
from the southwest of Scotland where the
Covenant heirs came from or as the
Highlands of Scottish Highlands which
were Presbyterian and Catholic and very
much of the old school and Gaelic
speaking were loyal to the king and sent
Highland regiments that were hated by
the the english-speaking Americans in
the northern colonies because they felt
they felt about them like the English
had felt about them back in 1745 the
barbarians and the more you get into
this you say yes a lot of the same
cleavages were there in Britain and
there several Americans have written
books about this but they've written
somewhat convoluted because a number of
parliamentary boroughs and and other
constituencies had petition drives
supporting or opposing the Americans in
other words did you agree with the
government did you want a conciliation
and in all the areas that had the heavy
dissenter populations and had been on
the side of Cromwell back in the English
Civil War that's where you were most
likely to see a substantial majorities
coming for conciliating the colonies and
the largest British cities all produced
pro-american in the sense of pro
colonial petition
and support bases especially London
London the London Council refused to
give any money for raising troops to
fight for the British crown and John
Wilkes it was a very well known
pro-american member of parliament
actually raised a fund for the the
children and widows of American soldiers
which they solicited for and you could
do this in Britain now what you couldn't
do was the same thing in the American
colonies if you were a Tory you were
going to be tarred and feathered
but in tyrannical Britain where George
the third was the second incarnation of
Godzilla or something you could call him
every name in the book you know there
wasn't anything they could do about it
so there was a little skew there but in
terms of the patterns representing
regions and cultures and religions it
really did in a very big way was I got
into this this is 1996 or so I'm
convinced that what I have to do here is
essentially a book about the three
emerging Republican majority's capital
Arwen too small are because they each
involved one of the major
english-speaking civil wars the three
major english-speaking civil wars and as
I got into them it became clear that
there were these genealogies these
lineages these shared circumstances and
and how they would interpret what was
going on in the light of a history that
was really kind of old at this point
except that's the way history often
works it lingers longer than you might
think not perhaps in white-hot intensity
but in a considerable folk memory so as
I got into this I became convinced that
these emerging Republican small R and
capital are constituencies or we're very
repetitious and who had a first of all a
regionalism for those anybody from New
England probably knows that in Eastern
Connecticut and eastern Massachusetts
who have an
number of towns name for towns in East
Anglia which is the little thumb in the
mitten of England which sticks out
towards Denmark right down east of
London and that was the area that was
the seedbed of the English Civil War the
strongest area for Parliament the
Puritans and that was precisely of
course the area from which New England
draw the bulk of its drew the bulk of
its settlement in the American
Revolution New England was the the
principal fulcrum of the American
Revolution if you go back and you see
who was causing trouble for the British
beginning in the late 1760s all the way
down to 1775 it was more New England
than anywhere else
the Virginians were pulled in more in
the 1770s because of some major disputes
over tobacco which they too made into
conspiracies Thomas Jefferson there are
three or four great Jefferson quotes on
the conspiracy of the tobacco merchants
to suck them dry and I can see why it
was part of the navigation actually had
the senior tobacco to Britain but what
that had the effect of doing was the New
Englanders were the stalwarts
ideologically religiously and with a
heritage of Cromwell the Virginians had
been on the Royal aside in the English
Civil War but it was very clear and in
Connecticut for example where we live
the flagship of the rebel Navy in the
American Revolution was the Oliver
Cromwell it was a smaller ship it was
called the young drama and for all I
know the dinghy that took you out was
was the baby Cromwell but there's a town
called Cromwell and so forth and so on
and in Massachusetts it wasn't far
behind this was the sport spirit this
was the element that we're looking for
the fight they didn't need tobacco all
they needed was their heritage their
religion their sense of who they were
culturally and governmentally you get to
the American Civil War know England
again
but at this time it's not just New
England its Greater New England it's not
the six states it's upstate New York the
northern tier of Pennsylvania the
Western Reserve of Ohio which was the
Western Reserve of the state of
Connecticut northern in the end and
northern Illinois all of Michigan
Minnesota Wisconsin the northern half of
Io this was greater New England that was
the seedbed that was the crux of the
demand for the civil war on the part of
the north the areas that were closer to
the south or in the Ohio Valley
so-called butter nuts they weren't
nearly as supportive it took Fort Sumter
and Lincoln calling for 75,000 troops to
get most of those people off the fence
so once you've got three centuries three
wars the same basic driving group of
people now in addition to them you had
some very important allies that were
there most of the time and in the
English Civil War the die-hard Puritans
weren't any kind of majority in Britain
they probably weren't even more than 15
or 20 percent but they had an awful lot
of support from what you could call the
the low church Anglicans the country
party people the people who didn't
believe in Bishops they liked a nice
easygoing Church controlled by the
vestry that didn't get in the way of
their foxhunting but basically they
wanted to run things themselves they
didn't want the King to do it and those
people were allies many on the
parliamentary side of the Puritans you
get again to the American Revolution the
perfect parallel is with the Alliance of
the the Tidewater tobacco planters in
Maryland and Virginia and then other
planters and Anglicans down in South
Carolina they were all located in want
bishops either and their allies were the
Presbyterians and Congregationalists up
in New England so there you get the
three war is you've got a sort of
similar pattern those are the basics
high church Anglicans and generally
speaking but not quite as cleanly
Catholics would be on the other side
those were the groups that were most
likely to be opposed and you'll say
was that true inthere in the revolution
high church Anglicans were very very Pro
Tory in the American Revolution a
Catholics in the United States were
divided but those in Ireland and
Scotland were heavily on the British
side and furnished a number of the units
that came to fight it's not 100 percent
it's just a good framework for building
this and seeing how it goes and when you
take Britain during the American Civil
War it's the same as it's very hard to
convince Americans that the English
Civil War could have mattered worth a
darn in the United States although even
in one battle the Battle of the Severn
it was where the often appleís Maryland
it was where the Puritans have been
kicked out of Virginia teamed up with
some of the Anglicans in in Maryland
against the the Cavaliers from Virginia
a few of them but mostly the Catholics
associated with the Calvert faction
which was a royal colony and/or royal
proprietorship and in Maryland and a
little version of what had gone on on
the other side so it was there in any
event hard as it is to believe you find
all these things working and in terms of
the the high church Anglicans even in
the American Civil War a number of the
religious histories and this isn't the
religious part of this library JP Morgan
was a very active Episcopalian and there
are bound to be some elements I've
always felt more comfortable this part
of it in a congregational or
Presbyterian Church but there even in
the American Civil War there was a the
Episcopal Church was divided a lot of
the Episcopal leaders in New England and
the North were were very soft on the
civil war some of more copperheads the
leadership of the Confederacy in South
Carolina in Virginia was quite
substantially Anglican there was a
bishop Pope from Louisiana who actually
fought as a Confederate
Major General while he
was the anglican bishop of louisiana now
to say that that was a major force is
overstated it's just that the the
Anglican view like the Lutheran view and
the Catholic view was not marshaled
against slavery did not take a position
on slavery and they didn't have this
Reformation astute of the extent that
the the low church Protestants
especially the Presbyterians and the
congregation listed and it's it's not
hard but it's not that the time and the
place to go through all the church
details in the American Civil War and
the thing is that it's absolutely
stunning you can go through and your
types of Baptist or were different
whether they were free will or otherwise
the old and new Presbyterians that was a
major cleavage in the war the so-called
ante mission Baptist who didn't want any
do-gooding room and of course the
ultimate do-gooders were the New
Englanders who would interfere in
anything you know you don't want a Bible
in your hotel room will have five you
know you want to walk to a circus on
Sunday don't all the all the drys Lyman
Beecher who was a real activist on the
Congregationalist and Bluenose side he
lost a Church in one New England town
because the fire department thought it
was such a great thing that features
Church burned down if they wouldn't do
anything they're all sitting around you
know having a swig for the most part
problem all of this is difference came
through loud and clear in terms of the
defining characteristics in the American
Civil War it's the a lot of the
newspapers and periodicals and books at
the time referred to New England as the
eastern states and there's several
virginia theorists who would develop the
notion that this is a it's another
version of the reformation fights and
the in virginia you represented the
very the more easygoing people and these
are the blue noses and they're into
every kind of manufacturing and every
type of social do-gooding concern and
what-have-you and you know again I just
no way I can sit and go through all of
this but it is just fascinating to see
how in unfurls
and I've spent for better or worse
almost 50 years on American voting
patterns and history and every county in
every River Basin and what-have-you and
in the country and as a result I was
able to go through and I guess much more
quickly than most people could do sort
this stuff out and pull it together and
it was just fascinating to see these
three wars and of course these three
Wars shaped so much of American politics
and then you wonder why these cleavages
are also visible in politics today and
they still are and the the Bush
administration for example right now
it's a very substantial program underway
to try to rally Catholics this being the
new group that's perceived as the
religious linchpin but when I was
involved in Republican politics which
really goes back some 30 years the key
was that the South would break up and
that the fundamentalists and everything
a great bulk of the white Protestant
South would be at loggerheads with the
Democratic Party on religious issues on
cultural issues on racial issues on war
issues on Harvard Sausalito and Ann
Arbor issues you know whatever you want
to pick that it was just ripe for the
plucking culturally and religiously and
now they feel the final thing that they
have to pull together or the Mexicans in
particular but but also Catholics
broadly so all of us continues and it
continues because in a country that has
heterogeneity and sections that are
important in all kinds of ethnic and
religious differences those issues are
unavoidably in the
or form and the trick is to manage them
and in the United States they've been
managed because you had to have
toleration because nothing else would
work you've had a crazy quilt the other
countries where there are only two or
three facing off against each other you
get what happened for example in
Northern Ireland or what happened and in
in Belgium whether Fleming's and the
Walloons hate each other now it's very
hard probably to tell the difference
between a Fleming and a Walloon or
offhand I would guess that probably 95%
of the people here couldn't but you
might have trouble in northern I don't
want to unless you saw them coming out
of church what history is such that you
can make this enormous Lee important set
of yard sticks out of this and it's
really what we've seen let me close by
saying that I think in a lot of ways all
of these cleavages are with us still but
that they're weaker now and they they
exist only in a very loose form if you
say that in the seventeenth century in
the English Civil War they were
white-hot the American Revolution they
were still red-hot and they're really
worth all the controversies over bishops
in the back act and many other things
and the American Civil War they were
still there they're there now but
they're only an odd limited backdrop but
the whole role of fundamentalists in
politics of a cultural difference
between the the north and the south I
felt back in 1968 that we were in
something that's very close to a civil
war in the context of the late 1960s in
1968 and it was one in which the poles
of the Civil War reversed and you really
the loser was New England and Greater
New England New England and Greater New
England became the strongest support
base of the National Democratic Party in
1972 with McGovern in 1984 with Mondale
and in 1988 with Dukakis
and in in the last election you have the
incredible situation of Al Gore of being
the first southern Democrat to lose
every southern state and carry a
majority in New England because the
Democratic Party has shifted its
polarities and this whole upheaval and
it's not that the mason-dixon line has
crumbled that it's not there anymore
which has suck what some people thought
in the 1960s 1970s you know it's not
going to matter much anymore we're gonna
lose our civil war divisions well that
hasn't happened if you look at
impeachment the strongest support for
impeaching Clinton came from his own
south and the part of the country with
his most opposed was New England so that
a lot of this is ongoing it's just at a
much reduced vane but it still carries
important aspects of this country and
it's its beliefs and its patterns well
let me stop here and I'll be glad to
pick up on any of these points or get in
any other questions you might have
aha and the medal on the back war of
1812 once saw the demise of federalism
when saw the same kind of cleavages and
yet it's not something that seems to
have been a matter of discussion either
than the purpose of this lecture what
was there about it was it just it was an
American problem
there's perceived by the Americans the
question is basically why didn't I put
the war of 1812 in there and should it
have been in there and did it make any
difference and so forth essentially I
would not rate that as one of the major
english-speaking civil wars if you were
chesapeake in the gary era i suppose you
would have rated it right at the top but
if you weren't it didn't matter that
much it was a war that the british
didn't want to exert a whole lot of
effort to win and one that we really
didn't win except for the fluke at new
orleans which happened after the treaty
had been signed in in kent six weeks
earlier now the the importance of this
politically was enormous because the the
principle stronghold of the Federalist
Party which was actually the party that
included simultaneously a lot of the
Congregationalists New England power
structure but also a lot of Tories the
Tories such as they weren't American
politics tended to go under the
Federalist Party and it was logically a
pro British party for a lot of reasons I
can go into a lot of detail on that but
suffice it to say that if you look at
politics in New York in New Jersey and
Philadelphia and Maryland and South
Carolina and North Carolina Clare Torry
concentrations tended to be some of the
strongest areas for the Federalists and
they were supported in terms of trying
to get all sorts of
non sequestration of estates non
forfeiture of political rights one of
the principal lawyers was Alexander
Hamilton
so the Tories were busy milk the
Federalists were busy milking this for
all it will work they did not want to
fight the British so much of knowing
one's trade was with Britain and frankly
I think that the the Jeffersonian policy
towards the maritime sector was
ridiculous the embargo was ineffective
and very negative for the the Commerce
of the the port cities but anyway to
make a long story short the British
burned Washington in the summer of 1814
it didn't look like the war was going
very well the Federalists decided to
hold something called the Hartford
Convention which began in December of
1814 concluded in January of 1815 and to
some extent their leaders were thinking
about seceding but that wasn't on the
agenda they didn't talk about that but
it was a very ill-advised meeting and it
wound up looking ridiculous and it wound
up tying the Federalists to the tale of
treasonous image and the Federalist
Party was an enormous difficulty even
before then and was in a lot worse
difficulty and survived nowhere but in a
very small and petering out way in New
England New York Delaware and you can
sight Maryland in New Jersey but it's
reaching so I don't regard that war as
having had much effect it wasn't at all
clear in its its military outcome it
didn't cost anybody a whole lot it was
embarrassing for the Americans it was
embarrassing for the British
bad blood continued but it doesn't rank
as a major
errand really one last point on that you
the British American hostility for about
80 years more would be in what involve
disputes Geographic disputes within
North and South America up until the the
1850s in North America and then after
that and in the Western Hemisphere that
was the yeren not not the war of 1812 in
the back how do you plug in Bush's
faith-based program now to some of the
things you said about the roles that
religions that played and your statement
about how do you see that well I figure
that this is cross between the religious
strategy and his father's thousand
points of light a thousand points of
light for those who forget or the that
desire to harness all of America's
charitable and nonprofit organizations
as individual little points of light
that when reaching through the darkness
and so forth I don't think anybody
remembers any particular point of life
for anything laughs and it's sort of
went the way of the education presidency
but the political strategy is a very
definite one and the idea of rewarding
religious institutions and organizations
with a greater public policy role than
they've had I think is one that they
strongly endorse now how effectively
this will be done I have no idea but I
think they take it seriously I tend not
to take it too seriously because the
thousand points of light get in the way
of my thinking about it but it does have
a strategy in mind absolutely
there's a link obviously between the
opposition in the American Revolutionary
period by the Quakers to slavery and the
ongoing opposition to slavery it's the
cause of the Civil War could you comment
on what some of your discoveries about
the links between abolition in the
United States and religious groups
before the American Civil War well it
was really a very vivid pattern you can
I don't think anybody has directly
written a history or political science
or religious for that matter textbook on
this but if you were to take the
individual religious groupings and
denominations and sub denominations and
analyze their positions on slavery you
get a a very useful guideline to what
they thought about the Civil War and how
they voted and the one that struck me
the most visibly and I won't get this
right so I won't try to do it in any
great detail but you had very fresh
German immigration to the United States
at that some of the Civil War huge
numbers of Germans came over in the
1840s and 1850s and a lot of them went
to states like Ohio Indiana Michigan
Illinois Missouri Wisconsin Minnesota
and with the exception of Missouri those
were all very important swing states and
what was the most recently developed
part of the country that was really
adding population and the Republicans
were very anxious to get German votes
and Abraham Lincoln even bought
behind-the-scenes control the principal
german american newspaper in illinois to
do this lincoln was somebody who prided
himself on looking like a Yankee having
come to Indiana across a flight boat on
a flat boat from Kentucky and owning a
German American newspaper it's sort of
like in New York politician who went to
Ireland Italy in Israel
the Germans were that important at the
time but in order to deal with the
Germans and to make sense out of their
politics the first thing was that the
basic German Protestants and Catholics
didn't care for each other that much
they would unite against anybody trying
to kill beer on Sunday and things like
that that got German unanimity across
the church line but as soon as you got
into questions of slavery and government
as a moral agency and so forth you began
to run afoul of all these distinctions
within German Protestantism to say
nothing of German Catholicism and after
all this is the country why should we
expect that they would be backward that
had the 30 Years War and had Luther and
many many others and the notion that
they wouldn't find as many different
ways to fight about this religiously as
the anglo-saxons this is misguided they
did well these churches all have the
different Lutheran's at different
positions on slavery the Missouri Synod
was it was sort of straddling but didn't
didn't take a position some of the
smaller groups did there was a Norwegian
old-school Lutheran group that wouldn't
criticize slavery and for some reason
they correlated very strongly for a
while with Democratic support in and
what was very aunty slavery Upper
Midwest and in Wisconsin you get into
the German divisions it even had to do
and this is where I lose it there's no
way I can coherently regurgitate back
stuff I could barely read frankly but it
depended on how the northern German
state became Protestant and whether the
ruler was a whole Hager or a straddler
really and if they they took a fierce
brand of Lutheranism were shaded toward
later towards German reform then they
would be more likely to be a Republican
and anti-slavery
but if they were liturgical and if they
were a Lutheranism that was barely
distinct from Catholicism as was the
case in several in the North German
states then that Lutheranism got
involved in no social reform didn't take
a position on the slavery issue and they
tended to support the sort of Democrats
who straddled a slavery issue then you
German there was a German Methodism of
some sort and then of course when you
get into all the different Pennsylvania
Dutch weathers there shuang Felder's or
the Amish or the the Hutterites or
Mennonites or and others and I can't
keep all that straight either and I'm
not going to try I mean I think of them
in buggies on the roads but it sort of
runs down after that but believe me
believe me this was big stuff and it
wasn't in the American Revolution too
the correlation between the religious
aspects and we have people had well and
what they did economically you would get
some correlations i wouldn't regard them
as really good correlations because
they'd be Carlos correlations based on
overlaps as opposed to causalities
for example if wealth and Quakers would
correlate pretty nicely Anglicans and
and wealth certainly in the New York New
Jersey area there'd be a correlation
there in some of the rural parts of
Maine for example the Anglican parishes
were poor they had a mixed bag of people
ethnically and they were not the ruling
anglo-saxon class which was
Congregationalist but you can find
correlations but this is where other
aspects come in in a very important way
in New England the percentage of
Congregationalists that would have been
Tories would have I can't imagine it was
even 10% it was probably 5% 6% 4%
whatever and among those I think it's
probably a pretty good bet that most of
them held positions under the crown or
or had some commercial tie based on
being on the coast they were importers
they did a lot of trade with Bristol
among Quakers however you get an
interesting mixed bag in which the the
wealthier were probably the more
cautious and in places where they could
be cautious they wouldn't take a side if
they were forced to choose a side
then if there were too many
Presbyterians around they'd often go of
the British the the Quakers and the
Presbyterians couldn't stand each other
in Pennsylvania and it's not an
exaggeration to say this there was a
gang of a Presbyterian scotch-irish
Roughnecks that came in from the West
came into Pennsylvania to Philadelphia
the Paxton boys and basically they'd
been involved
some Indian massacres but at the same
time they had a somewhat valid case for
the Quakers not wanting to spend much
money to defend the frontier and it was
the it's clear in the literature of
Pennsylvania this is one of the few
times the Quakers mobilized and actually
took up arms they were so anxious for a
shot at a Frontier Presbyterian if they
put down all the stuff about non
militarism and they were there so when
you get situations like that it's hard
to have the correlation work terribly
well with the wealth but having said all
this it is very fair to say that people
who held appointive offices whether they
were sheriffs or judges or customs
officers or what-have-you or doctors
were very likely to be loyalist a lot of
lawyers were because the court work tied
in with obviously with the British
colonial government so you would have
had a correlation but it was offset if
you had an area where it was very
strongly Presbyterian or
Congregationalists where you just
wouldn't have much support Vittorio's
Imperial and you would get the the
correlation with with Toryism if rich
were Anglicans made a fair part of the
the wealthy power structure in and
around Boston was Anglican and they were
lopsided Lee loyalists there were very
very few Boston Anglicans that were not
loyalist as there were very very few
Boston Congregationalists that weren't
on the Patriots up riches in in in New
England went hand-in-hand with smuggling
to and the more smuggling in vitamins
you had the more likely you were to be a
patriot who wanted to kick the bejesus
out of the British customs courts so too
many things cross rougher than and mess
it up
it's been suggested recently that the
Gettysburg Address was a kind of
preamble to a second American
Constitution do you see any connection
at all between the Gettysburg Address
and the pattern that you've been
describing going back to the English
Civil War I would say not the the
Gettysburg Address one of the reasons it
could be passed over so much as it was
in the immediate reaction after the
speech where all the attention went to
Everett and nothing to Lincoln was that
it was shortened didn't touch any of the
hot buttons and it was you'd have to
read things into it later
you weren't touching on any of the
things that were we're radical at the
time so I don't I think Lincoln for
example every yardstick that I can not
every yardstick but but a plurality a
majority of them would suggest in 1865
that he'd become very concerned about
the the radicals in Congress getting out
of hand
certainly unhappy about what he saw
developing as a size of corporation and
capitalism that went against his very
deeply held theory of the labor value
labor as property and as a result I
would not think that the politics that
was probably building up under Lincoln
had he not been assassinated would have
been a one that was on the radical side
of any of the issues which were going to
be developed into radical issues by the
strong reconstruction mind of the
Stevens types or the people who
ultimately took the 14th amendment and
made it apply to corporations and then
claim that they consented to do that all
along
I it's difficult for me to sing Lincoln
as being a part of that politics would
he have taken a different view as to
seriously empowering blacks in the south
so that they could maintain their
citizenship when push came to shove I
doubt it because almost no part of the
Republican Party wanted to tinker with
the property arrangements in the south
very much and unless you did that you
weren't going to be able to support the
black franchise for all that long but
there's some people and I guess I happen
to be one of the cynics that I think the
Republican intent with black
enfranchisement in the South was was
quite political and by the time 1876
rolled around they had consolidated more
of the political and governmental and
economic side of what they aim to do and
didn't feel the need to win with the
black votes in the south anymore it's
not to say that they would like to have
had them but you didn't keep it going in
the face of that I'm assuming that when
you take the the Gettysburg Address the
one thing that can be teased out of that
more as a moralistic view of how the the
war had to be an instrumentality of
reform and change and I don't think you
would have done that on the economic
side I don't think it would have done it
on the hard-nosed political
reconstruction side and the moral side
is so abstract coming out of the
Gettysburg Address that I wouldn't bet
along on that either but you know that's
just my view and I certainly can't
recite it here and tell you the
different phrases on which I'm basing my
judgment aside from one or two of the
obvious ones
I don't see it I'd say thanks